foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
O'Leary Mr Wonderful we're here in San
Francisco at converge our first crypto
ecosystem conference uh thousands of
people uh here it's a great setting and
it's just wonderful to have you uh here
with us for this conversation well great
to be here Jeremy I remind you I'm an
investor in you I am very aware
and I'm very optimistic that things are
going to work out here
well it's been uh it's been it's been
quite a journey and actually maybe a
good place to start I uh I'd love to um
maybe hear you talk a little bit about
your own kind of journey into this space
and and uh and I've been able to have
somewhat of a front row seat to some of
that uh but it's been you know it's been
amazing to see all the things that
you've gotten involved in as well but
just talk a little bit about kind of
when did that click and and and then you
know what you've been up to well I'm
often reminded that I was a vocal critic
of crypto uh in 2017. there's a clip of
you and I actually on television you're
correct and uh that gets shoved in my
face and in other orifices all the time
and uh but but I I change as a my job as
a fiduciary so I when when rules change
I change and I have to because the
people that I work with and four uh
realize that there's tremendous
opportunity in this space and I have
come to the realization just on a
categoric basis that within a decade
this will be the 12th sector the
because it provides so much productivity
so much transparency so much opportunity
for all other sectors in terms of
financial services that it will find its
place we're in a difficult area now
because we lack regulation but my whole
journey into it particularly stable
coins is the frustration I have as an
international investor in payment in in
the the absolute inefficiency and cost
of moving money between geographies
which I do every day and I've detailed
many catastrophes where I'm transferring
capital and it gets lost for 48 hours or
it gets lost over a weekend or I can't
find what happened to it for three or
four hours and I can't close
transactions and it turns out that Banks
we're never good at this and they're
still not good at it right well the the
realization I had when I actually
started working on Circle was that money
is essentially record-keeping systems
like it's ledgers right and whether it's
a ledger at the central bank or a ledger
at a commercial bank or the
old-fashioned like ledgers that you know
the medicis or whatever were using and
and you know the the technology when you
kind of peel back the onion and you look
at underneath like what is the
technology that you know makes money
either move slow or move fast or be
expensive or not expensive is a lot of
it is just like this incredibly
Antiquated you know kind
you know models of of keeping track of
of this information and blockchains are
a you know a much more open accessible
transparent auditable real-time
publicly available infrastructure and so
it's it is kind of like once you have
that and you start using it
and you think about that compared to
what you deal with in the Legacy world
it's like oh my God I would very much
like to use it uh for for for reasons of
all those plus the efficiency of moving
it and and the Le so you know
something very important happened last
week when
Jamie dimon on the hill a manager I have
ultimate respect for I'm an investor in
his his company as as every fiduciary is
it's a five percent waiting in any Index
Fund uh it is it is the best managed
financial services company in the world
one could argue when he actually
there's no better words than to say took
a [ __ ] on crypto in front of every
legislator which was a huge disservice
but also a wake-up call to to make it
blatantly obvious that he was talking
his own book
he can't do what you can do and he knows
that and at some point he's going to
realize that because his clients are
going to say I want to use that service
maybe in conjunction with what I do with
you but they're just better at what they
do in a payment system
to me it was a turning point because
we're kind of at a low on legislation I
know you're working hard along with
others along with me there's private
investors that go to the hill I'm one of
them
I mean when are we going to get some
policy on this because it was a story 36
months ago that everybody understood we
had to wait but now it's it's becoming
apparent that we are falling behind as
an economy on this and you're one of the
guys leading us I'm going to reverse
roles here for a second what are you
doing to fix this Uh Kevin it's a it's a
it's a good it's a good question I mean
look a couple thoughts um one just on on
on uh on diamond and his comments I
think it's really easy for uh for for
quote unquote critics to take a [ __ ] on
things
um when a market you know market price
has changed there's volatility all this
sort of stuff and you're seeing a lot of
that out there right now where people
are like oh you know these these markets
are off and so I'm gonna like and you're
talking about specifically the
catastrophes and stable coin of recent
times yeah catastrophes and stablecoin
catastrophes and other parts of of
crypto markets and and other things as
well and so I think and you know these
lending companies that went Belly Up and
all this yeah so there's like this sort
of stuff and I think that that makes it
people who want to be critical they can
kind of come out in full force uh
whereas certainly doing that yeah yeah
but I think it's it's like super
um it's it's I think it's shallow and I
think it's short
it's not really thinking things through
do you think he feels the threat of this
change to his fundamental Service as a
bank well you know I
certainly get inside his head and
thinking about this what I would say is
and I'll come back to your to your
question is
um you know a payment stable coin that
is essentially like a token
representation of cash that is
essentially a mixture of cash at the fed
and short-term U.S government treasury
bonds that is a that is the sort of
in some ways like would be the safest
digital Dollar in the world whereas a
deposit at a Commercial Bank whether
it's JPMorgan or any other is that's a
loan to the bank and the bank is then
lending the money and you got a claim on
it but it's different and so I I think
that the idea of full Reserve Banking
and full Reserve dollar payment systems
is a really powerful concept that whose
time has come and I do think that is
threatening that is threatening uh to to
to institutions that have built their
payment systems around you know
fractional Reserve lending and uh and
this so a little bit of a digression I
think coming to the question of of you
know what am I doing about it I mean
look we have been advocating in many
forums in many venues for federal
uh payment related stablecoin
legislation and I think the good news is
that
this is something everybody agrees about
so certainly on a bipartisan basis who
doesn't want to support the US dollar as
a default payment system support the US
dollar uh everyone agrees there's a
bunch of of risk that exists and we need
rules around it we need to have clear
rules so that terrible things don't
happen to both end users customers
businesses uh Etc everyone agrees what
those risks are and and basically how to
address them meaning the kinds of high
quality liquid assets that should back
these the kinds of reporting
requirements kind of restrictions on
what you can do everyone agrees about
that and so the interesting thing is
whether it's the fed or treasury or or
Republicans Or democrats
everyone kind of agrees on what needs to
be done and I think so I think you know
we're really close we're really really
close like as we speak you know people
are grinding it out in Washington trying
to get to land on a bill that would
establish a federal model for stable
coins which we think would be huge for
the U.S huge for this whole market so
we're really close
um but you know we live in a a
federalist system you've got States
you've got the federal government you've
got well I I know I know the bill you
speak of everybody knows it's it's
public knowledge that this thing's being
worked on and those that are Advocates
and go to the hill
you have
issues with the states who don't want to
play it that way everybody knows that
too so you're going to have to calm them
down or whatever yeah you also and I'd
like you to speak to this because I want
the answer so does everybody else you
got a turf war going on here and who's
going to regulate this is it the FED is
it the SEC or another agency who should
regulate let's just stay on stablecoin
the one thing that that would make sense
to go first because we're not going to
save every token here we're not going to
have a blanket bill for everything
stable coins could be very useful right
now and who should regulate it well I I
mean I think like
as you've said right you want to be able
to use this for payments yes and you
want to for exact all the things that
you've seen as an international investor
as someone who's building businesses
Works in in in the movement of money for
for all kinds of professional means you
want to be able to use this as something
that is as good as cash and is accepted
as like a digital cash instrument all
around the world and that
the something that is in fact a version
of the dollar uh just like a bank
deposit it's like a version of the
dollar
that is the domain of of the Federal
Reserve
um and an eloquent solution because if I
felt the FED who regulates the dollar
the currency itself was also regulating
this it would tie the brands together
for all stable coins that we're going to
use the dollar I mean we're speaking as
if you're the only stable coin you're
not many yeah there's many there's going
to be more right and that's part of this
legislation is to create a way to have a
clear path for whether it's Banks
non-banks uh you know yeah let there be
competition I'm fine with that
absolutely but let me ask you another
question that's it is on the mines let
me represent the institutional market
for a moment that must by definition be
compliant and that means they have their
own compliance departments as I have
they have Auditors and they have The
Regulators that they report to
what's missing here and your work is not
done is giving us the infrastructure
that lets us be compliant in a fashion
that's open and transparent and easy for
people to work with now you know I've
I've been using the circle account for
over a year now it's getting better all
the time the treasury tab all that stuff
but you're not finished yet no there's
you know in order
you know to take cash and say okay let's
move 50 million into this thing and
start paying you know to manage our
fundamental treasury operations right
fundamental treasury operations because
it's it's a sweep account it needs more
dashboarding more structure yeah are you
working on that yeah absolutely so
um one of the exciting things that we
have going on here at converge is we're
going to be talking a lot about where
we're going with all of our platforms
and we kind of have this concept of kind
of business banking what is the future
of Treasury accounts what are all the
things that you're going to be able to
do
um it's a huge investment area for us so
it should be we have a vision for what
the next generation commercial Financial
account looks like that is a hundred
percent digital asset based and that
allows people to seamlessly interact
with uh you know counterparties whether
it's in payment experiences or in you
know dealing with the you know ways in
which people are interacting with with
defy and other things and so we
definitely are advancing it and I think
coming back to the regulation question
um it's really critical that you know
everyone from the CFO to the compliance
Department the third party accountant or
accounting firm
Etc that everyone knows what are these
financial instruments where do I put
them up in my books and Records how do
they get reported how I how do I treat
them if I accept a payment with this
from a customer what is that right and
this it's the unglamorous part of all of
this well it's the most important it is
actually like foundational so so
actually here's an issue that that I
have in many institutions have right now
we cannot call our stable coin in my
case it's usdc that does not get placed
in a cash sweep on my balance sheet
right now it is essentially to my
Auditors and compliance a rogue currency
it is because there is nowhere they can
go to get the assurances that this is
tangible
and it should be considered cash yeah
it's hasn't broken a dollar and I argue
well this should be treated as cash and
they said well show me where show me the
regulation so this is the key and and it
it ties to like who should regulate this
and things like that but it also is you
know and this ties into the broader I
think digital asset space as a whole
which is we need National
definitions we need to say here's what
this is It's defined at a federal level
and it and then everyone can say okay
here's the federal statute for what this
is and here's how it's treated if you're
holding it and how you're protected in a
in bankruptcy it's you know here's
here's what we know it's composed of
Because by law it has to be and so it's
a cash equivalent to be sure you won't
care if I keep it in Zurich or if it's
sitting in London it doesn't matter
because that's where it's going if you
got me that that's where I would be
going yeah I mean the power of this is
that this is dollar digital currency
that works on the internet
um and so and yeah you're going to have
you're going to have lots of of digital
asset intermediaries that provide
products and services everywhere in the
world but they're they're going to be
able to settle transactions with each
other at internet speed and and
virtually no cost okay let's talk about
another area of disappointment again
speaking now as a crypto investor across
many many positions I've got
at least 40 different projects I'm an
investor because I believe in
diversification I don't know with
certainty which ones are the attraction
the eth merge was a huge disappointment
if you're an investor I mean you're down
huge on that and you know it has Merit
but it it's not what people thought it
was going to be and it's still
misunderstood but
leaving that aside where I see a lack of
adoption now is because wallets are too
complicated for the every man totally
it's a mess yeah and and we're just it's
problem for you too I I think about this
as like
for the next 500 million people to a
billion people to get involved in this
the crypto of it has to go into the
background
so you know the things that you need to
know like you know what is this long
string of texts and numbers and like
what if I got that wrong and I couldn't
paste it wrong and like what are what
are gas fees like all this stuff way too
complicated like
I can tell you for example with email
all the underlying like protocols and
this and that that makes her email go
and makes it work so that when you hit
send it gets to someone else but no one
cares they just log into their Gmail or
whatever it is and it just works it took
a long time it actually worked it did
right it took that was five six years of
iterating and stuff and I think that
this is a critical piece of the next uh
of the next wave of adoption is user
experience uh making it safe
kind of safety and user experience
whether you're a retail individual or a
Treasurer inside a company right those
have to get kind of solved and those are
the things that will unlock this on a
mass scale so I 100 agree with you that
you know that we're you know we have the
Jeffrey Moore's famous technology
adoption life cycle curve and you've got
the early adopters and then crossing the
chasm and then the early majority we're
still staring over the precipice of the
chasm right now like we're we're the
early adopter phase and you know the
leap to the other side you know the
early adopted phase people tolerate the
analogy of a baseball game if we're
going to get crypto to the 12th sector
the s p which I think it will get to and
that will be a very big outcome for
investors like me I'm so nascent in one
of these projects I don't know which
ones are going to work but I only need
two or three to work right and they'll
be very valuable
where are we first ending second inning
third inning
yeah you know it's interesting yeah like
at Circle
um when we got started
uh yeah I founded the company with my
co-founder over nine years ago and there
was my view is that it was like a
20-year journey I had hair when you
started the company so did you probably
I'm aware of that yeah
um and I think we had some basic ideas
about what it would look like to have a
protocol for dollars on the internet
that could could be open and
interoperable and so on those are the
ideas we had nine years ago and I
thought to get to the place where this
stuff works and it's fast and it's
scalable I thought it would take about
10 years and so we're kind of on
schedule for that and that's like a
that's like the Starting Gate right once
you get to that then you're then you're
like okay now how do you scale this out
for all the users you really thought 500
million people would use usdc yeah you
can't do that on ethereum
well so I think you can do it on the
different scaling models that exist so
layer twos on ethereum
um are showing a huge promise polygon uh
you know optimism arbitrum these are all
emerging and then there's a lot of
competition in in the base these these
base protocol layers layer ones I'm glad
to see it yeah but I'm thinking but
we're at a place though where in the
next two to three years you probably
remember very well when we had the first
you know we had dial up internet and
then we had Broadband but it was kind of
like you know Telephone Company
Broadband that was like ah it was like
four times faster than dial up right DSL
or you know you had these kind of things
it was it was shitty it wasn't very good
yeah so we're right in that we're right
in that phase where we're kind of like
in the DSL of blockchains and we're and
we're getting really close to the fiber
optic and so that that's key right if if
Will you will will you pick
a platform because there's lots of
competitions salon and polygon you
mentioned uh Missing the new a new idea
I mean well we're you know you know we
we um are you going to support them all
we're we're adding more and more here at
converge
um you know we've announced uh adding
Cosmos polka dot uh arbitrum optimism
near and there are more on the way and
we've also announced a cross chain
protocol that makes it easier for
developers who are building those wallet
apps to not have their users to have to
worry about it or care so that you can
send or receive no matter what because
in reality if if you get regulated and
are one of the regulated stable coins
this is where the use case starts to get
interesting and
for the new user that comes in that's
that is is is waiting for a lightning
speed transactions they don't want to I
mean if your credit card took you 47
they don't want to think about it they
don't want to think about it so so you
you want to drag some of those platforms
with you to provide that speed
absolutely yeah so you know I think the
important thing is
you know there are a lot of a lot of
competing infrastructures I also use the
analogy of
um you know there were 17 mobile
operating systems at one point and
everyone you know compact Microsoft Palm
Pilot Nokia NTT Samsung everybody had
some other competing smartphone
operating system
um and no one knew at the time which one
was going to get the developers and
which one was going to become usable by
a billion people
obviously Steve Jobs got it right came
in was patient and delivered something
that everyone could build on and then
was cloned obviously or copied to some
degree by by the likes of Google but I
think you know do we have the iOS of
blockchains yet
maybe maybe it's maybe it's in front of
us right now but we're going to see that
emerge and that's going to be really
critical to the kind of scale that we're
talking about so let's talk about
something else because there's a
parallel path developing for blockchain
that is is you know gotten a lot of
press mostly negative nfts
um the this this first iteration of of
apes and jpegs and they have basically
been wiped out I mean it's it's fun and
it was interesting to see them trade for
half a million dollars and then just get
wiped out but there's also Brands out
there and I know this because I'm I work
in certain verticals I'm a huge watch
collector and in the watch industry the
secondary Market is much larger than the
primary Market every watch that's made
by Rolex is sold and there's nothing to
buy from Rolex right now just an example
but there's billions of dollars of
Rolexes that have been in the market
since the 50s that are trading every day
unfortunately many of them fake and so
what that what that's what the secondary
Market wants is to use the blockchain
through nfts to authenticate
authentication physical Assets Now in
the negotiations we're all having and
the discussions we're having and I want
your opinion on this
when these are used to authenticate
paintings and watches and pens and
jewelry and real estate and cars and all
these all property right so what is that
is that a security because I'm going to
add a little Nuance to it one of the
reasons the watch industry is looking at
this and there's a group of us that are
in the horological societies I'm one of
them we're pointing out to the makers
like a Patek Philippe an FP journ a
Rolex right every time the secondary
Market trades your watch you get nothing
yeah and it's trading at 400 percent
higher than what you made it for you're
in the same situation that a rock band
watches and happens to the secondary
ticket Mark of a hot show
wouldn't you like to get three to seven
percent yeah I mean it's it's such a
it's such a great powerful thing but
what is that is that a so that now that
nft authenticates the maker
authenticates that that was made in the
factory and then it starts to trade in
the aftermarket is that a security
paying a utility dividend
we'll have to see what lawyers think
about all that but
um but what do you think I I don't think
so I mean I I think that that these are
technologies that make it possible to
have better records to authenticate
property and the ownership of property I
think if you're if you're
fractionalizing the ownership then
you're Crossing into not fractionizing
it stays with the piece from owner to
owner yeah I mean I think the idea that
you have um you know kind of uh you know
royalties or equivalent you know
Downstream payments that as as a piece
of property is is bought or sold that uh
the originator of that property uh can
can receive uh you know a piece of the
payment associated with it I mean you
you have structures like that that are
certain nft protocols like the nfts that
get minted can only be transacted and
transferred through the protocol and the
protocol itself includes includes that
senior age essentially for the
originator so there's there's ways to do
it even at the protocol level and I I
think that's that's more of a commercial
Arrangement uh for the the buying and
selling of property
versus a security there's not and you're
not making an investment uh
for you know an expectation of profit so
it's always the effort of others if
you're buying an art if you're buying
art down the road when and I'm a buyer I
would want the authentic I would want to
own the nft that authenticates that
piece of work yes but the state of the
artist should that person be passed
right would get a royalty because it's
trading and every decade when it trades
again at a higher lower price they get a
piece yeah to me that's a commodity that
is not a security right right yeah
you're dealing you're dealing with the
transactions of Commodities so we could
end up in a place where you
fractionalize an nft as a security
that's right with a prospectus or if
it's an authentication vehicle it's a
commodity I think that's where we got to
get to yeah I mean I I mean part of this
is just like how do we use nfts
and the utility that comes from them uh
which unlocks all kinds of different
forms of entitlement around ownership
whether it's the the Creator or uh or
someone who possesses it and
entitlements that they might get
um so I think you know early days there
but it still has huge huge uh potential
as well so let me hear your thoughts on
this because
um
guys like Sam bankman freed have tried
uh you know binance has tried the really
big firms
to get the message out about crypto to
commercialize the message and it's been
a real struggle because the the there's
a there's a really tight small crypto
community
of of of really rabid fans if you want
to call them right that's in my view
starting to hurt this space because a
lot of them don't believe in regulation
a lot of them believe in decentralized
only a lot of them are rogue in terms of
the way they think some of them are
founders of these chains
that's not helping because to get the
500 million you're talking about to use
this stuff
people have to feel safe about it they
have to think okay this is just a better
mousetrap yeah and everybody else is
using it where where do you sit on the
Continuum and I could call you out on
this are you a Founder Fundamentalist
or are you you know an advocate for full
regulation full transparency are you
somewhere in the middle are you trying
to keep everybody happy which I'm
finding is impossible well
I am more in the middle but I think
um I've always believed that we're we're
simultaneously
building a new internet we're building a
whole new layer of the internet and it's
really vital that there are kind of
first principles that can be upheld in
what that infrastructure is maybe I
should ask the question a different way
more binary more black and white are you
for regulation or not
I think regulation is critical
for the financial applications of this
the the technology is useful in so many
domains even outside of Financial and so
the key is what we don't want to do is
over regulate the infrastructure layer
itself because that is to me just like
trying to regulate you know internet
protocols I mean for for usdc which is
that makes sense that is I can't even
use it yeah if this doesn't get I mean
we we're we're only able to offer the
product we do today because we actually
did launch it in a regulated manner
through the money transmission rules and
payments supervisors you built it to
roll on the on the regulated highway but
it's not the regulated highway yet
because my auditor won't let me call
this a cash equivalent which is
extremely screwed up yeah so clearly
like it's a constant kind of upgrading
of that kind of statutory uh okay
environment yeah but you know there is
and you will certainly get some of this
in this conference and thank you for
hosting it I think it's a lot of a lot
of influencers and thinkers coming here
to and many will air their frustration
as I will because this is getting really
boring like we we got to get something
done here yeah talking about I think
that's right I mean this is like and
I'll be beating this drum you know uh
not just here but but off all through
the remainder of this year which is like
the time is now for Congress to act this
isn't just going to come from an agency
issuing new rules this requires Congress
to act because it's novel and new and we
need these clear statutory definitions
and statutory swim lanes and so now's a
critical time for the United States to
act and it is making the United States
look ridiculous the fact that our
Congress cannot get together on
something that is so clearly going to be
a vital part of the way that the
internet economy works for the next you
know decades and so it's a it's a
pivotal moment from my perspective I'm a
little optimistic on on that of late the
last few weeks because when I first got
to the hill everybody was holding on to
their bill as if it was their brand and
now there seems to be consensus that
they don't care which Bill gets Advanced
whoever's got their name on it they're
going to support it we've got to figure
which I think is a major move as we're
going into the midterms to see that you
know yes Hagerty and Tumi and Hildebrand
they're all yeah pushing what everyone
was going to go yeah and I think that's
very bipartisan I think you've been a
big advocate for that you've got a good
job on that yeah
um I also believe that the one thing
rule just getting stable coins done yeah
it's the lowest saying fruit yeah it's
the lowest hanging fruit but it would
also signal to the rest of the crypto
Market primarily the Institutional
Investor Market I actually think that if
you and this is a speculation that if
you got this thing done with with just
stable coins and you got it regulated it
would increase the value of a lot of
different and positions I have including
I'm happy to hear that because they
would make the Assumption because we're
stuck in in a 17 to 22 range on bitcoin
and we're never going to get out of that
if we don't get institutional support
it's just going to sit there forever
it's not a bad outcome for miners of
scale they're making getting awards at
seven to eight thousand they're trading
them at 17 to 20. but it's really
getting old and it's it's losing its
momentum as an idea because it can't
seem to get anywhere well this is a
breakthrough moment technologically in
terms of user experience in terms of
regulatory in terms of you know what you
know people delivering on you know the
the real utility value of all this and
um I mean you're I think you're dialed
into all the right themes for for what's
what's needed here
um I think I think I am but but I'm I I
hit I go everywhere where I can make you
know when I can talk about it
to people that will listen I'm very
fortunate to have a massive platform to
speak to but there's a fatigue in this
market now yeah and there's a lack of
adoption and there's a lack of wallets
that we talked about there's a lack of a
lot of stuff and it's really coming to
the front now people are saying we got
to break through this it's like a giant
Log Jam yeah well that is what we are
trying to do uh as an industry uh and
you know converge is uh we're we're
bringing all the players together and
the big theme is from speculative value
to utility value like that's the key
we've got to grow for you that's you're
actually the test case you are you're
the anchor of that yeah you are
definitely the canary in the coal mine
here and it's a remarkable time it would
be great uh if you
we're able to announce some regulation
on this thing it would be a game changer
yeah I'm very optimistic if anybody can
do what you can there's a lot of people
rooting for you a lot of investors
rooting for you A lot of people that
want to use the product that can't yeah
it's really time
um and so you know let me speak on
behalf of the entire industry
get this [ __ ] together if you like that
video will you see my next one don't
forget to click right over here and
subscribe